it's autumn in germany
the nights are drawing in
and the sun becomes a rare sight
when you wake up and it's dull and gray
outside and there's no sun it darkens
your mood too
there's plenty of sun where i come from
in germany there isn't even enough sun
for me in summer so i miss it all year
for me
it was hatchback i work out a lot and i
want to do something for my appearance
so i'll feel better
i might go to the solarium so i'll get
some sun
the designers in the lima office in
berlin know how important light is for
people
the group has already had a number of
projects they've illuminated everything
from stairwells to entire office
buildings
is a lighting designer he specializes in
making interior light as close to
daylight as possible
we wake up when it gets light and we go
to bed when it gets dark
sunlight is our reference point and you
can't improve on that
you can only simulate it very closely
there are many ways to use modern
lighting elements
they can be found in swimming pools and
in offices
in museums or doctor surgeries
but new forms of lighting are also being
used in private homes as well
economical led lighting means there's
more space for light than ever before
one can deform
you can change colors several times and
let them run through automatically
you can also create an image and use
light to set the scene to make the space
always look different
and that's always something pleasant
berlin's
hospital is carrying out research on the
positive effect light has on people
a small intensive care unit has received
new lighting
two four bedrooms have been redesigned
to offer patients more privacy and
comfort
illuminated ceilings are supposed to
promote healing
as
that shade is conducive to feeling
protected
the space has been designed
architecturally to make it seem like a
living room rather than that storage
area feeling you get in other ic units
illuminated ceilings are supposed to
relax and entertain patients they can
play with the system's elements to
change the colors look through treetops
or gaze at moving clouds
he's expecting a cold loud intensive
care unit room then he wakes up and sees
how friendly it is that there's light
above and it's not so loud
i think patients enjoy it
businesses are also trying to shed new
light on themselves
a shopping center in berlin's helensdorf
district is being refurbished and
equipped with an led lit ceiling
list
light is a major driver of feelings of
well-being in both private and public
spaces
given that using lighting technologies
in an interesting and intelligent way
can influence passers-by's feelings of
well-being and contribute positively to
their willingness to buy in person
ceilings like these cost about 100 euros
per square meter the price increases in
proportion to their complexity besides
looking good they keep energy costs down
too
two good reasons to lift your mood and
come into the light during the autumn
and winter seasons